what's the issue you have with
globalization like what are some bad bad
things say about it well i mean look the
great example is what we're just talking
about here with afghanistan is that we
believe that we have a set of values and
customs and morals and a virtuous
framework that we can go and just apply
universally to civilizations across the
world does not work
people are different
and they don't want what we are selling
right you have to occupy for for i i
don't think three generations i think
four generations okay yeah no by their
country or in their mind enough to have
all of the people who remember the old
ways pass on dead and then the next
generation remembers nothing and says
this is the way things are they've
always been right right so that's one
element the second element of
globalization that's no good for
everybody is it the the race to the
bottom on wages and environmental
standards which is what the with and i'm
i'm throwing environmental standards in
as sort of a joke but that was the
argument against the 1999 wto ascension
of china into the world trade
organization of which black bloc the
precursor to american antifa was
protesting well black black bloc was
just a tactic
uses the black bloc tactics so it was it
was ant it was leftist activists using
the black bloc tactic same as antifa in
opposition to the world to the world
trade right and their arguments were
actually organizations were actually
pretty salient
we'll have a global downward pressure on
wages we'll have a global downward
pressure on environmental standards and
what happened all that [ __ ] all that
stuff went to china and they you know
their environmental standards are much
lower wages when exported all around the
place and what happened our entire
middle class and industrial uh you know
support within the united states has
been completely hollowed out and
offshored so like globalization
the fundamental problem with
globalization is that our cultural way
of life is unique to us as a people
it is not a universally applicable to
every civilization and person around the
world and that is a hubris and arrogance
that we have to get over but that's and
you're right and that's what a lot of
these dictators and conquerors all
believed
at every single one of these
authoritarian dictatorships who are
expanding and taking over thought this
universal set of values the set of
values we have is universal and can be
applied the thing about the the
communists that's different from us and
to a certain degree is that they were
like we'll just kill anybody who opposes
us yeah the u.s does that to a certain
degree to a certain degree but they
genuinely try to buy people
it's the capitalist approach just give
them money and comforts it's really
amazing you give them something to lose
whereas the communists were like we'll
just lose them right
well what's interesting too about
communism is that it's like sub-nation
state it's like below the level of
nation-state it's a way to unite various
factions and people in different nations
against the nation-state that they're
living in which was what the end of the
west valiant era and the west valley
treaty was supposed to be about which is
supposed to be about like
nations here not meddling with their
ethnic group and there in that nation
and like setting up these boundaries so
that the conflicts were actually between
nations but then communism came along
and made it so that people across
different nations and boundaries could
unite around a common cause and become a
common faction because a common problem
now that's not you know totally
notwithstanding all the issues around
communism but that is one of the
interesting conflicts it presents with
the nation state system as we have it
now i think one of the things that we
have to appreciate as americans
is that our american way of life our
values our virtues our constitutional
republic our representational government
all these things they're not universally
applicable
not everyone in the world wants it not
everyone in the world needs it not
everyone in the world is going to thrive
under it it is specific to us in our
context and our geography and our
history and our language and our
religion and our people and that's why
it works for us it's our thing you know
you know what i absolutely loved this i
i there are many things i've done in my
life and there are many things that i've
experienced i'm like this is amazing
going to taksim square in istanbul and
istiklao amazing because i'll tell you
this so you've got toxic square
obviously the riots and the tear gas was
certainly experienced i wouldn't call it
a net positive you know people giving
you like lemon juice to like wipe off
the tear gas i don't know if that works
just made it hurt more
but anyway so that was an experience but
no no no you was brilliant when the
conflict wasn't happening here i am in
this in this beautiful park with people
doing their thing and they're these
really old like several hundred year old
uh baklava shops and you go in and they
have all these different kinds of of
baklava it's amazing so delicious and
they would give you these little things
of ice cream with it and that was
something i never got anywhere i've had
baklava in the united states not the
same by my nose stretch i was there for
a couple weeks and i was gaining weight
i was like this stuff is too good it's
just drenched in sugar syrup and the
desserts they have they take like grain
and they twist it and spiral it and then
pour syrup on it and that was something
unique and that experience and i love
that walking down it's the call this
this is the cloud this long street uh
this long street i'll tell you what my
problem with globalization
i had that experience and the oh man and
the isla burgers you know that means wet
hamburger they take the burger they like
dip it in like they get all moist we got
to make these things it's like lamb and
then it's like they put this sauce on it
and then they steam it and then they
wrap it so it gets soggy and it's like a
buck and you're all drunk in the middle
of the night and you walk in and they
just take it out of the heater and give
it to you and everyone's just eating
them amazing what an experience and i
tell people like you haven't you ever
have like the islam burger and people
like whoa what's that it's this unique
thing
i went to uh the bahamas
get off the cruise ship and i'm thinking
this is going to be so much fun to bask
in the culture that is the bahamas and
you know what i saw mcdonald's
mcdonald's starbucks gucci hard rock
cafe and i was like
this stuff's next door to me i don't
want to go to the bahamas for this so i
had to walk into some neighborhoods and
try and find a local shop where they
were making local food and i was like
that's the problem it's gonna be like
everybody put on your grade jumps jump
jumpsuit shave your head everything's
the same no matter where you go anywhere
in the world it's mcdonald's and
starbucks welcome to globalization it
strips out the adventure and the
uniqueness and the decentralization of
the human experience agreed and in fact
we call that global homogenization
and that's something that we think is
really bad and so therefore i am in
favor of global homophobia that's what
i'm in favor of it
homogenous yes exactly my problem with
globalization is we had a guest on that
actually made this point i think or you
did about someone else that said it is
that it's inevitable it's going to
happen regardless it is how is it going
to actually not inevitable at the rate
we're going the expansion and
interactivity of human interaction yeah
ask victory
ask victor orban if he believes that
global homo homogenization is inevitable
the point is that i think that it might
be inevitable but how it's going to
happen is is not is is variable so what
there's been a push back against
political globalization people don't
want that people don't want that in the
u.s the internet people are terrified of
one world government so they're going
the economic route they're trying to
that's what's more cultural it's
cultural like with the movies and the
music and the film and the jeans and the
whiteness and all the things those
things are exported you can export them
across the pipes you can uh you know the
the internet pipes and the satellites
and the whole thing that's everywhere
have have you ever been and dude i have
been to third world countries in
backwater villages up the creek down the
way where there's like nothing else but
you know what you could get
you get three things you can get a pack
of marlboros you get a coca-cola you get
a johnny walker you can get those
anywhere johnny walker oh yeah johnny
walker johnny was all poisonous i tell
you this man when uh uh you know the
being in in egypt during the revolution
you see the mcdonald's
three blocks away yeah but that's
decades old that's that's been that's
been everywhere mcdonald's has been in
beijing since you know who knows how
long ago but the most important salient
factor in what we're talking about here
is the values
the political values the personal values
the morals the virtues the family
structure all these things that we hold
dear the virtues that the country was
built upon
i just spent some time studying with the
claremont boys out there in las vegas at
the fellowship okay one of the things
that we really was struck by when i'm
reading original texts original text
from the founders john j alexander
hamilton all these guys not only just
the around the federalists and the
constitution but around state
constitutions and the discussions around
state constitutions right so you get
real context it's not just the federal
thing it's in every state from everybody
and they all firmly believe the couple
of following facts one that you have to
build the government like a coat to suit
the individual
okay it has to be specific to the people
two that the american people were a
unique set of people bound by language
culture history stories experiences
blood race religion and so forth and so
therefore that the american government
was built as a coat to suit these unique
people
and we can't take that coat
tim imagine if we took my jacket and put
it on you that'd be really warm you'd be
really warm and you'd be swimming and
you'd be half lost in that thing right i
could probably make a pitch pitch a tent
put a stick up and then just sit under
pitch and tent he said get a little fire
going so if you gave me your jacket i
put it on i put it on like flex and i
bust the seams out like the hulk it's
the disaster right but it looks cool
so so this is what our country was
founded this is not just like one guy's
idea this was the entirety of the people
found in our country understood that our
people were unique our history was
unique our language and religion and
culture were unique and the government
that we built was unique for those
people
so this idea that we can take what we
have here for us a special kind of
people
and like just universally applied across
the world is asinine well what about
bitcoin i mean i think that we're we've
universally spread a concept
globally we're globalizing under a
currency yeah but that's just the idea
of money exists everywhere commerce
exists everywhere exactly on earth but
you know i'll put i'll put this away
i'm 50 50. i think there needs to be
strong international ties but there
needs to be sovereign respect so what i
mean to say is is there something is
there something we can do to make sure
that a country's borders
laws
and customs are respected
and
we prevent war we prevent major serious
international conflict and destruction
and havana syndrome or nuclear weapons
you know what's funny is that the wars
that we have been involved in are
because we want to exert our way of life
on other people
i'll tell you i'll tell you here's the
problem it's utopian the idea yes i i
think i think globalization
is very very likely and the issue is
there are people who are willing to die
for their ideology or seriously harm
others and they're people who aren't and
you know the united states is a bunch of
hyper-individualistic
uh um you know right-wing nut jobs in
the middle of the woods with a bunch of
guns and i mean that in the best way
possible i mean like we got a whole
bunch of people who are sitting on a
pound on a mound of beans with guns and
be like i'm not gonna bother you you
don't bother me and i'm like right on
brother yes so it's very hard to conquer
that's not everybody though there are a
lot of countries where they're like you
know my god is the one true god
therefore and they're gonna they're
gonna fight and they're gonna attack and
then you have communists who have found
subversion to be the powerful method and
so now you might have that
hyper-individualistic dude who's you
know living in the in the mountains
who's minding his own business
respectfully peacefully and he's well
prepared but all around them the cities
are falling to subversive ideologies to
to submit to break apart the d we have
we have a relatively decentralized
system here compared to many other
places
yeah by design and so you can subvert
that
and that's what what communists and
marxists and others have been doing so
ultimately what i see is those who are
willing to oppress lie cheat and steal
have a major advantage and they've been
winning in that front
and that's because
the difference between what we have here
and what they have there
and at least at the time of the founding
and for most of american existence was
that the american citizenry was devout
christian
okay and so this is the fundamental
issue
is that
our declaration of independence is based
on natural law and natural rights which
come from
the creator
and in the christian belief the creator
is a monotheistic god so there's only
one god and if you've got other gods
you're wrong
so we have one god natural law natural
rights american constitutional republic
that's the direct lineage and the
declaration of independence and that's
what everybody at the time thought when
they signed the thing
and so if you believe at the same time
that there's only one god and that
everybody else's god is wrong well then
there's almost a compulsion to spread
that ideology to other people but i
think that we need to do is just respect
the fact that other people have
different ideas and i interviewed
alexander dugan the russian philosopher
who pushes his his ethnic
multi-polarity ideas
because he believes that people are
different based on their geography and
their location and their history and who
they are inside etc and that they evolve
into needing different political regimes
people have evolved to need diff
different political regimes
the chinese for example have evolved in
their own civilization in their own
context with their own everything so
they've evolved their own political
regime just like we have here in the
west but population growth
will lead to borders pressing on borders
there's no free land anymore for the
most part there's like some rock like
volcanic rock i was looking at down by
antarctica that's like an unclaimed
thing trying to find unclaimed land here
it doesn't exist you can build islands
sure sure but the point is that we've
reached it used to be like okay it's no
big deal because there were a lot of
places that were just open send them to
the
colonies yeah and and they're
ill-defined territories so people who
are like people with claims remember
when there was just like claims on land
well we claimed this and we claimed that
no now there's nations everywhere i have
a weakness
so now what happens when china says we
need to expand and as we expand we need
more resources and we can't get access
to resource x because it's not within
our borders let's go ask them for it
what would you want will not give you
anything for this resource but we have
to have it otherwise our people are
suffering when a population of any
species grows too large and the amount
of resources levels out
everyone suffers you see it in every
every overpopulated species deer pigs
turkeys whatever they become sickly they
become malnourished and they fight
become aggressive because there's just
enough resources to sustain their
current level of population so then what
do you think is going to happen to
people when in a country like china with
1.4 billion they're like we got to get
food somehow we're importing it from
australia what happens when these other
countries start saying we're not going
to give it to you well we're not going
to sit here and die and now that there's
no unclaimed land someone's going to
have to give up what they did claim well
you bring up an interesting point which
is that every other country around the
world shares the perspective that i am
putting forth right now which is that
there is no universal morality no
universal virtue no universal political
regime no universal constitution that
should be applied no universal rights
none of it no one else believes that
except for us well there is a universal
thing is economics it it is everything a
bank a bank can can cut your your
account they can they can remove you if
you talk about disrupting the
decentralized union of the united states
yeah communism but banking
they can hear what
finish this one thought before we get on
to that which is to say that the chinese
people aren't looking at their chinese
government being like everybody here
needs to be chinese all around the world
we're going to export chinese ideology
everywhere no they're thinking
mercantilist right and that's one thing
that we haven't woken up to is the fact
that china is mercantilist their
national trade policy is to enhance
their national
uh standing and their the good the good
uh benefit to their people okay that's
why they do trade which is to make their
nation stronger as a nation for foreign
policy and national domestic policy
issues but they're not out there trying
to say everybody needs to be chinese
communist party no they're like we want
that food we're going to go get it which
is a totally different perspective than
what we have which is like we have to
end tourney all around yeah but that
that idea of any terrorist propaganda it
was it was a way to sell war to people
because we want to extract it it's
definitely not it's 100 not it goes all
the way back to woodrow wilson
it goes back um they conquered in the
name of defense i i will i will say at
least in america it goes back to woodrow
wilson and the initiation of the
progressive policy and modernity and
scientific method and the improvement of
everything can be reduced we can
eliminate evil we can eliminate disease
it's reflected in the covent zero
policies that people have especially in
australia and what's in in america as
well it's this idea that we can perfect
things perfect things perfect things so
if there's evil out there we can perfect
it but i i disagree we did not get
involved in syria because we wanted to
bring freedom and bashar al-assad was an
evil dictator it's because for a long
time we've been trying to build a
pipeline the cutter the qatar turkey
pipeline and syria said we will not
go against the wishes of our ally russia
who says no to this because they want
more control through through gazprom et
cetera et cetera and so then true back
in 2009 the guardian reported this a
couple years later that the u.s said we
will have ground troops in syria soon
with the next few years and then
surprise surprise when as soon as
there's an opportunity for the u.s to
get involved and give weapons it's it's
it's interesting you're pointing out
competing factions you're pulling
competing factors let me say something
interesting we in the american
revolution the french says the french
say we're at war with the british hey
these colonists are going to help us
let's supply them with arms and then it
worked and the americans get
independence in syria the u.s sees this
uprising and they're like and depending
on who you ask by the way because the
leftist will say it was a cia conspiracy
from the get-go but they see this
opportunity with this uprising and
they're like we should arm some of these
people
because we don't like bashar al-assad so
they intervene to provide resources to
the competing faction hoping that once
it topples we'll be able to build that
pipeline nothing to do with freedom
everything to do with opportunistic oil
pipeline building i agree i agree with
that i think what you're pointing out
are competing factions within the united
states foreign policy apparatus you're
pointing out factions where people have
like monetary
monetary excuse me monetary interest at
heart but at the same time there is this
progressive ideology in our foreign
policy in our domestic policy that's
reflected in the gender policy and the
marxist policy and the feminist policy
and the critical race theory policy
which is all about like perfecting
things and making perfect through
science and the scientific method and
like eradicating evil and spreading
freedom and all the great things that we
have all around the country did you see
the report from project veritas oh about
the the teacher the teacher in
california he's got mao we got mao on
his wall i have 180 days to turn these
kids into revolutionaries yeah uh
i think it's one of veritas's most
important stories to be honest and and
it's like it's like some random dopey
dude but this is important because you
know a lot of us are familiar with the
goings-on of google because everyone's
got their complaints the left says oh
it's a monopoly that won't ban hate
speech and everyone's kind of focused on
them and complaining and it's the
censorship stuff's overt thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time